how big are they?
How much room is that?
How many server racks could you fit in there?
And for some data centers,
you might get two of these pieces of information.
You know how much they spent,
and they also, say, because they had to contract
with the local government
to get the power provided,
you might know what they made a deal to buy,
so you know how much power it takes.
Then you can look at the ratios of those numbers,
and figure out for a data center
where you don't have that information,
you can figure out,
but maybe you only have one of those,
you know the square footage, then you could figure out
well, maybe the power is proportional.
And you can do this same thing with a lot of different quantities,
you know, with guesses about the total amount of storage,
the number of servers, the number of drives per server,
and in each case using what you know
to come up with a model that narrows down
your guesses for the things that you don't know.
It's sort of circling around the number you're trying to get.
And this is a lot of fun.
The math is not all that advanced,
and really it's like nothing more than
solving a sudoku puzzle.
So what I did, I went through all of this information,
spent a day or two researching.
And there are some things I didn't look at.
You could always look at the Google
recruitment messages that they post.
That gives you an idea of where they have people.
Sometimes, when people visit a data center,
they'll take a cell-cam photo and post it,
and they aren't supposed to,
but you can learn things about their hardware that way.
And in fact, you can just look at pizza delivery drivers.
Turns out, they know where all the Google data centers are,
at least the ones that have people in them.
But I came up with my estimate,
which I felt pretty good about,
that was about 10 exabytes of data
across all of Google's operations,
and then another maybe five exabytes or so
of offline storage in tape drives,
which it turns out Google is
about the world's largest consumer of.
So I came up with this estimate, and this is
a staggering amount of data.
It's quite a bit more than any other organization
in the world has, as far as we know.
There's a couple of other contenders,
especially everyone always thinks of the NSA.
But using some of these same methods,
we can look at the NSA's data centers,
and figure out, you know, we don't know what's going on there,
but it's pretty clear that their operation
is not the size of Google's.
Adding all of this up, I came up with
the other thing that we can answer, which is,
how many punch cards would this take?
And so a punch card can hold
about 80 characters,
and you can fit about 2,000 or so cards into a box,
and you put them in, say,
my home region of New England,
it would cover the entire region
up to a depth of a little less than five kilometers,
which is about three times deeper
than the glaciers during the last ice age
about 20,000 years ago.
So this is impractical, but I think
that's about the best answer I could come up with.
And I posted it on my website. I wrote it up.
And I didn't expect to get an answer from Google,
because of course they've been so secretive,
they didn't answer of my questions,
and so I just put it up and said,
well, I guess we'll never know.
But then a little while later
I got a message, a couple weeks later, from Google,
saying, hey, someone here has an envelope for you.
So I go and get it, open it up,
and it's punch cards. (Laughter)
Google-branded punch cards.
And on these punch cards, there are a bunch of holes,
and I said, thank you, thank you,
okay, so what's on here?
So I get some software and start reading it,
and scan them, and it turns out
it's a puzzle.
There's a bunch of code,
and I get some friends to help,
and we crack the code, and then inside that is another code,
and then there are some equations,
and then we solve those equations,
and then finally out pops a message from Google
which is their official answer to my article,
and it said, "No comment."
(Laughter) (Applause)
And I love calculating these kinds of things,
and it's not that I love doing the math.
I do a lot of math,
but I don't really like math for its own sake.
What I love is that it lets you take
some things that you know,
and just by moving symbols around on a piece of paper,
find out something that you didn't know
that's very surprising.
And I have a lot of stupid questions,
and I love that math gives the power
to answer them sometimes.
And sometimes not.
This is a question I got from a reader,
an anonymous reader,
and the subject line just said, "Urgent,"
and this was the entire email:
"If people had wheels and could fly,
how would we differentiate them from airplanes?"
Urgent. (Laughter)
And I think there are some questions
that math just cannot answer.
Thank you.
(Applause)